Traditionally biomedical research, when you
do an experiment, it tries to reduce the heterogeneity
in the data to make sure that when the conclusions
are made there is no known confounding factor.
What we have been focusing on is using a lot
of data that's very heterogeneous —
some might call it dirty data — and use this
large amount of dirty data to identify a signal
for a disease that is conserved across multiple
independent data sets and is clinically useful.
And we've shown that this approach works in
a broad number of data sets, a broad number
of diseases — including autoimmune diseases,
organ transplants, infectious diseases, cancers
— for identifying diagnostic and prognostic
markers, new drug targets, and so on.
We applied our dirty data approach to identify
a diagnostic signature for tuberculosis.
One third of the world is infected with latent
tuberculosis and about 180, 190 million people
worldwide have active disease.
But even in the 21st Century it's very difficult
to diagnose active TB.
And what we were able to show is that using
almost 2,600 blood samples from 11 different
countries in 14 independent cohorts, we found
that there is a three-gene signature that
distinguishes who has active TB from who has
latent TB, who has other diseases that look
like TB, and who are completely healthy with
a very high accuracy.
Now what we are working on showing is that
it also allows us to predict who's going to
have active TB much, much earlier than clinical
diagnosis.
It collates with treatment response and that
it can be used as a screening tool for identifying
the patients who may have active TB and should
be treated as soon as possible